tu reçois maintenant anny duperey pour
la parution au seuil des chats de hasard
un récit dans lequel la comédienne comme
hugo baudelaire avant elle rend un cas
récent hommage à nos petits minous bref
du père et donne sa langue à tous les
chats salut anny duperey alors les chats
de hasard donc le livre on le voit
pendant que magie de la télévision on
voit partout parlons c'est
extraordinaire et donc avec couverture
de l'auteur est croqué à l'intérieur
comme j'étais maire de lauterbourg alors
les chats de lazard sait déjà quoi que
vous avez jamais choisi qui sont arrivés
dans votre vie oui j'ai appelé les chats
de hasard ce qu'on rencontre qui marque
une période de sa vie où qui qui ont
vraiment un sens tout à coup qui tombe
dans votre vie au bon moment et puis
enfin en ce qui me concerne moi j'en ai
eu deux comme ça qu'ils m'ont choisie ou
qui sont arrivés ou que j'ai trouvé et
qui ont justement eu des rapports
exceptionnelle avec moi j'aimerai
toujours demandé si c'était justement
hasard aussi le fait qu'ils étaient un
petit peu destinée sur ma route ont fait
qu'on a eu des rapports exceptionnel ah
oui j'ai des chèques qui vous ont
accompagnés on va parler de votre vie et
puis au fur et à mesure des événements
de devenick et qui est riche en
événements d'ailleurs il faut bien c'est
un livre prétexte offre oui et vous
parlez de vous être averti sait pas que
sur les chats il ya un côté vous avez
pas m'en vouloir d un côté un peu mémère
à son chat des fois c'est à dire que
quand même ça peut même avec la
turquie tempère j'espère ne pas l'être
alors et en même temps il ya votre vie
en contrepoint avec toutes les aventures
qui vous sont arrivés donc évidemment on
va trouver dont on trouve dans ce livre
des choses qu'on avait vu dans le voile
noir on va y venir jean louis barrault
jean mercure etc évidemment tout ça est
très lié à l'or premier problème votre
vrai nom c'est le grave et bien fait de
changer et oui alors il y avait un
monsieur legras déjà sûr mais alors du
périmètre où et comment différé c'est le
nom d'un grand père à moi qui n'étais
pas d'ailleurs mon vrai grand père qui
était le mari et mari de ma grand mère
mais c'est un nom qui est dans la
famille quand même c'est un nom qui est
dans la famille bien alors à nyon le moi
j'ai vu écrit trois façons différentes
ny mais il ya un moment où vous l'avez
écrit à m y a non non pas jamais jamais
nous on s'amuse erreur de rue je me suis
dit que même là c'est bon non je suis né
après-guerre donc c'était on américanisé
un petit peu alors c'est le seul parce
qu'après si ginette annoncé comme moi
thierry ça faisait comme ça c'est un peu
exotique appelée mariage alors alors
vous êtes né à rouen premier chat là on
y arrive un premier chat dans un
quartier qui s'appelle les martinsville
qu'un quartier insalubre c'est un
quartier qui étaient des touristes avec
des usines de tannage des teintureries
un petit canal et là bizarrement
d'ailleurs au milieu de ce quartier un
petit peu insalubre on l'a dit il ya
vous aviez votre avis y avait un petit
jardin y avait un jardin et dans lequel
il y avait beaucoup de chats c'est vrai
que j'ai été élevé avec 13 h à huy et
que j'ai quitté bond quantique j'ai
quitté ce quartier et puis j'en ai plus
pendant 20 ans mais c'est vrai que j'ai
bon j'ai revu un petit peu ma vie et
puis en même temps j'avais envie de
parler de nous à travers le rapport avec
les animaux oui quand vous allez alors
ce qu'il faut dire parce que de toute
façon vous l'avez écrit donc ce n'est
pas un secret c'est que votre père avait
30 ans était photographe et puis un jour
le 6 novembre 55 j'avais 8 ans et votre
soeur patricia cinq mois et tragédie vos
parents meurent asphyxiés dans la salle
de bain
c'était le chauffe eau qui était cassée
c'est ça oui parce qu'on a pensé mais
c'était oui c'était d'effectuer toute
idéologie de carbone alors vous vous
êtes beaucoup culpabilisé plus tard
parce que vous êtes resté ce matin là
dans le lit je n'ai pas bougé j'ai
culpabilisé en pensant est ce que
finalement j'aurais pas pu les sauver
tout ça vous avez écrit un bouquin
s'appelle je vous écris qui étaient les
lettres vous avez reçue après la
publication mes lecteurs qui m'ont voilà
finalement libère quand je dis ça parce
que si pour libérer parce que dont je
vous écris il ya un toubib qui vous
anime et vous savez vous deviez être
vous aussi un petit peu intoxiquées un
petit peu asphyxié c'est ça je suis
peut-être un des camps mais mende est un
des seuls auteurs dont la vie a été
réellement changé par ses lecteurs oui
oui c'est vrai oui oui c'est sais c'est
qu'une différence genius toujours oui
peut-être de les avoir dix ont laissé
mourir c'est ce sont mes lecteurs qui
m'ont games en déculpabiliser en vous
disant fini mais pas mais j'avais des
médecins voilà vous en savez quand il ya
quelqu'un qui a intoxiqué à côté on
pourrait bien être victime voilà c'est
une merveilleuse aventure c'est clair
mais votre vie votre vie est tout à fait
étonnante vous aviez souvenir vous dit
une phrase très belle vous dit si
j'avais souvenirs comme un éclat d'obus
et tirs comme quelqu'un qui aurait reçu
un éclat d'obus il apostrophe fermé par
dessus un oui alors vous vous retrouvez
les photos de votre père vous hésité
pendant un an avant de les regarder vous
écrivez ça et alors là quand vous
écrivez ce bouquin donc le voile noir
qui a eu un succès considérable il faut
bien dire 191 c'est là vous vous avez ce
chaque ennemi sous hypnose alors parlez
nous de ce cher très honnêtement je vais
vous dire je pensais après le voile noir
et le je vous écris qui était la suite
de cette aventure merveilleuse avec le
public je pensais ne plus réécrire et
j'ai eu moi même la surprise là il ya un
an au printemps dernier de toutacoup
avoir envie et c'était pour moi une
merveilleuse surprise parce que je me
suis dit peut-être toute ma démarche
d'écriture n'a été que pour vider cette
chose de deuil et tant mieux si ça a pu
aider d'autres gens mais ça peut
s'arrêter là j'en étais un peu triste
parce que j'aime écrire mais je suis dit
après tout une démarche peut s'arrêter
là on n'est pas obligé d'écrire quelque
chose s'il n'y a pas de nécessité et
puis j'ai ressenti une très douce
nécessité
une très douce nécessité je crois que
c'était une nécessité de vie il me
semble que mon chat de hasard là c'est
la vraie fin du voile oui c'est qu'en
fait c'est vrai qu'il ya eu il ya eu des
je crois être pas être une mémère achats
mais j'ai eu des rapports exceptionnelle
avec un ou deux animaux et je vais
penser tout à coup qu'il m'avait fait
faire des pas dans ma vie tout à fait
étonnant elle est gage d'une personne
humaine est l'égal d'une amitié humaine
donc j'ai eu envie de rendre hommage à
ça et aussi de réfléchir tout à coup à
pourquoi tout à coup on a un animal
pourquoi on en a pas pendant 20 ans
pourquoi il tombe il tombe pas par
hasard dans votre vie et pourquoi tout à
coup on a des rapports avec eux qu'on ne
peut pas avoir avec les humains et mais
qui peuvent compter autant de relever le
voile noir de l'émission iquique qui est
près de vous alors après on est content
et ça très bien dans l'ue comme le chat
et vieux à un moment c'est votre si je
crois cliqué qui prévoit le deuil c'est
à dire devrait en prendra maintenant
c'est ma fille maintenant je sais quand
tu vas mourir adjoint serge est pas
tellement henri ii a priori de parler de
mes enfants dans les livres et je pense
que ça paraisse ça va s'arrêter là je
vais arrêter de raconter ma vie
maintenant mais ça s'étudie que votre
bouquin voix oui mais c'était tellement
extraordinaire que j'avais j'avais envie
de raconter ça à comment effectivement
une enfant qu qui dès l'âge de 6 ans
quand j'étais en train d'écrire le
probleme surement de mes parents mois
n'ayant pas accepté du tout du tout de
faire mon deuil comment elle a fait tous
les spas à l'avance pour s'accoutumer à
la mort non pas la mienne mais à la mort
d'un animal qu'elle adorait elle voulait
savoir quand il mourrait après elle
voulait savoir comment et après elle a
décidé qu'il mourrait sur elle ce qui
s'est passé elle a décidé qu'elle
apporterait en terre qu'elle irait à
l'enterrement jure heureuse là c'est
dans la creuse a oui c'est le film de
chéreau là c'est quand j'ai entendu un
hommage à ma fille aussi parce que j'ai
je ne pouvais pas imaginer qu'une enfant
est une force pareil moi je l'aimé pas
eu alors bon vous parlez du rituel de
l'écriture que tous les gens qui
écrivent connaissent mon chez vous c'est
particulièrement rituel dans quels
termes aux pour pas se lever pour aller
boire un café parce que c'est une
occasion d'arrêter de travailler donc le
thermos et sur la table et stylos
cahiers etc le shaq est toujours couché
là alors
vous parlez aussi de votre vie
professionnelle à travers les chats dans
ce bouquin parce que bon ce qu'il faut
dire c'est qu'après la mort de vos
parents prêtés par une tante une période
assez difficile vous dites on avait des
robes qui était ont refusé les robes à
l'envers quand elles étaient usés ça
c'est la période c'est laid c'est les
femmes de la guerre et parce qu'il y
avait quand même eu la guerre de 14
ouais et la guerre de 40 et un sens de
l'économie dans dans le milieu d'où je
viens moi qui étais un milieu ouvrier ou
un milieu qui avait pas d'argent quoi
est un milieu paysan même aussi il y
avait il y avait une science de ne rien
nous avons aussi dit un truc très jolie
enfin moi je les ai vus faire aussi en
martyr mais ces scellés woods savonnette
qu'on mettait ensemble pour faire un
titre multi colom parce que la couleur
de tous les saints alors déjà vous avez
quand même envie de faire du spectacle
passé quand il ya des valses de vienne
qui viennent à rouen vous essayez vous
dansez vous savez ça vous ouais pourquoi
je sais même que mouvement premiers
touchés au théâtre municipal 15 prend
des comptes est mon deuxième c'était le
french cancan à la foire-exposition
d'euros elle se savait pas alors vous
êtes premier rang seront aussi là vos
talons quand même
on peut les appeler noter que vous êtes
première en france est déjà une passion
de la peinture et le conservatoire de
rois aux beaux-arts de rouen remonter à
paris je suis de huit mois très peu de
choses bah si vous êtes doué pour
beaucoup de choses mais entretient
toujours les moins les mêmes les mêmes
depuis le début du siècle le théâtre la
peinture ce qu'elle coûte chasse par des
textes ouais
vous pouvez vous venez à paris donc en
banlieue et là à la garenne et là vous
quand j'étais petit j'aimais bien écrire
oui hélas vous écrivez à votre tante qui
restait à rouen et jusqu à ce qu elle
téléphone vous lui écrivait bijoux rien
bu de téléphones bas j'écris un roman
vous écrivez un roman donc et on en
parlera d'ailleurs qu'il a le miroir qui
beaucoup de succès en 76 alors au
théâtre pourquoi je vous parle de ça
parce que vous commencez au théâtre à 18
ans vous faites un film avec godard qui
était ou trois choses que je sais d'elle
parce que marina vlady été votre votre
copine ou donner le vertige à sur le
flash back mais lorsque je sais ce que
je veux dire c'est que vous avez quand
même au début commencé très bien dans le
théâtre puisque elvire popesco choisie
pour être la maman auprès d'elle dans la
mama d'andré roule ça
et puis là je sais pas pourquoi est ce
que c'est parce que vous étiez naïf
parce que vous manquiez de savoir faire
vous vous acceptez des films qui
finalement sont
vous ennuie donc aux non pas du tout pas
du tout c'était de deschacht douce et
très gentille le nom samassa ne m'a pas
nui du tout j'ai appris pendant ce temps
là j'ai appris j'ai appris mon métier il
faut faire des erreurs aussi
peut-être en ce temps là on n'avait plus
le droit d'en faire que maintenant on
avait le temps de faire ses armes on
avait le temps de faire des mauvaises
choses on apprend beaucoup dans une
mauvaise chose parce qu'il faut sauver
sa peau est alors toujours à cette
époque où vous décidez de revenir quand
même au théâtre à des choses un peu plus
un peu plus sérieuse que jerk à istanbul
vous faites hélène donc le faisait dans
la guerre de troie n'aura pas lieu et
les gens mercure et là vous raconter un
truc terrible dans votre bouquin c'est
qu'on mercure vous parle de l'élevage
des veaux voix batterie mais vous savez
il ya un point commun il ya je crois que
les gens les gens qui manie beaucoup la
séduction le large à dire les idées
comme comme ces créateurs qui était
quand même des metteurs en scène et
touya c'est là où ça va donner à
réfléchir quand même sur les liens qu'on
avec les animaux c'est cela que j'ai vu
le plus sensible aux rapports simples et
avoir une véritable fin vraiment un
besoin fondamental de ce rapport je vous
assure le visage de jean louis barrault
qui est toujours un peu [ __ ] vous savez
comme ça quand il regardait son chien
c'était extraordinaire parce que cet
oeil toujours un peu à la chinoise comme
ça devenait complètement rond il était
tout à coup complètement apaisé comme si
comme si comme si quelque chose de très
profond et est en train de s'abandonner
au contact de l'animal et on a tous
besoin de ça jean mercure vous dis donc
je vous parle des veaux en batterie mais
ça m'a beaucoup enfin gentil c'est
choquant parce que c'est pas vraiment
xevo sont élevées dans le noir avec les
pattes et qu'un terrible c'est terrible
et que les animaux se venger quand on
voit ce qui se passe maintenant
effective effectivement oui c'est pas ça
qui m'a dit exactement ça m'avait aussi
beaucoup frappé et m'a dit la souffrance
transmet way dit je suis persuadé que
une torture qu'il ne véritable torture
quand même d'élever un être jeune un
veau gère dans le noir sans bouger juste
juste l'empêcher de bouger je veux dire
l'empêché de voir la lumière est une
torture total edit je suis persuadé que
la souffrance reste inscrite quelques
braillards et quand on mange une chair
qui est imprégnée de souffrance il en
reste quelque chose et j'ai été jeté
dans la société c'est beaucoup mais bon
voilà alors on va parler du mot terminer
sur les bouquins de guilad miroir en 76
qui lui prix de l'académie française
quand même pas rien le nez de mazargues
80 cependant un des prix un des prix le
nez de mazarin 86 le voile noir 91 avec
je vous écris derrière et puis
aujourd'hui le dernier donc les chats de
hasard voilà la boucle est bouclée vous
croyez non maintenant par contre je
pense que non je vais écrire ouais je
vais écrire mais je pense que je vais je
vais peut-être revenir à la fiction oui
parce que c'est très agréable faut dire
que nous nous comédiens c'est vrai qu'on
joue avec soi même avec son tempérament
avec ce qu'on pense ça à travers des
personnages un coup je me montre que je
me montre pas c'est toujours sur une
fiction alors comme je le fais dans mon
métier c'est vrai que c'était
formidablement tentant tout à coup de
parler directement aux jambes ou télé
savez vous avez de la chance de pouvoir
tout faire comme ça c'est formidable
c'est rare je le fais avec coeur wild
thing et je suis ravi que les gens le
reçoit les corrections de ne rien rater
de l'inaptitude abonnez vous émettez un
pouce bleus